I recently had an epiphany I realized
that I could actually play a role in
solving one of the biggest problems that
faces us at faces mankind today and that
is the problem of climate change
it also dawned on me that I had been
working for 30 years or more just to get
to this point in my life where I could
actually make this contribution to a
bigger problem and every experiment that
I have done in my lab over the last 30
years and people who work for me did in
my lab over the last 30 years has been
said directed toward doing the really
big experiment this one last big
experiment so Who am I I'm a plant
geneticist I live in a world with this
too much co2 in the air atmosphere
because of human activity but I've come
to appreciate the plants be as amazing
machines that they are whose job has
been really to just suck up co2 and they
do it so well because they've been doing
it for over 500 million years and
they're really good at it and so we said
so I also have some urgency I want to
tell you about as a mother I want to
give my two children a better world than
I inherited from my parents it would be
nicer to keep it going in the right
direction not the bad direction but I
also um I have Parkinson's for the last
15 years and then this gives me a sense
of urgency that I want to do this down
while you feel good enough to really be
proud of this chain and I have an
incredible team that we like we all work
together and this is something that we
want to do because because we have fun
and if you had only gonna have five
people you try to save the planet you
better like each other because you're
gonna be spending a lot of time together
okay
alright but enough about me let's talk
about co2 the co2 is the star of my
No most of you probably think of co2 as
a pollutant or perhaps you think of co2
as a villain in the novel you know it's
always the dark side of co2 but as a
plant biologist I look at I see the
other side of co2 actually and that's
co2 that we see something we see it
differently because I think we remember
as plant biologists something you may
have forgotten and that is that plants
to actually do this process called
photosynthesis
and when they do photosynthesis and
we're all based carbon-based life and on
our words is all because of the co2 that
plants and other photosynthetic microbes
have dragged in from co2 that was in the
atmosphere and almost all of the carbon
in your body came from air basically so
you come from air and it's because of
photosynthesis because what plants do is
they use the energy in sunlight take
that co2 and fix it into sugars so that
it's a great thing and the other thing
that is really important for what I'm
going to tell you today is that plants
have a great implants and other
photosynthetic microbes have a great
capacity for doing this twenty fold or
more than the amount of co2 that we put
up because of our human activities and
so even though we're not doing a great
job at cutting our emissions and things
but the plants plants have the capacity
as photosynthetic organisms to help out
so we're hoping that's what they'll do
and so there's a catch here we have to
help the plants a little ourselves
because what plants like to do is put
most of the co2 into sugars and when the
end of the growing season comes the
plant dies and decomposes and then all
that work they did it sucked out the co2
from the atmosphere to input make carbon
based biomass is now basically going
back right back up in the atmosphere as
co2 so how can we get plans to
redistribute it redistribute the co2
they bring in into something that's a
little more stable and so it turns out
that plants make this product
and it's called suberin and soup this is
a natural product that are in all plant
roots and suberin is really cool because
as you can see there
I hope everywhere you see a black dot
that's the carbon okay and though it's
hundreds of them in this molecule and
where you see those few red dots those
are oxygens and oxygen is what microbes
like to find so they can decompose with
a plant so you can see why this is the
perfect carbon storage device and it
actually can stabilize to see the carbon
that gets fixed by the plant into
something that's a little bit better for
the plant and so why not why why is now
a good time to do a biological solution
to this problem and it's because over
the last 30 or so years and I know
that's a long time you say well white
now but but thirty years ago we began to
understand the functions of all the
genes that are in an organism in general
and that included you you know humans as
well as plants and many other
complicated eukaryotes and so what the
1980s began what began then is that we
now we know in the function of many of
the genes that are in a plant and that
tells the plant to grow and that is now
converged with the fact that we can do
genomics in faster and cheaper way than
we ever did before and what that tells
us is that all life on Earth is really
related but plants are more related than
other life on you to each other than
other organisms and that you can take a
trait that you know from one plant and
put it in another plant and you can make
a prediction that it'll do the same
thing and so that's important as well
and then finally we have these little
genetic tricks that came along like you
heard about this morning it's things
like CRISPR that allows us to do editing
you can make make genes be little
different from the normal state in the
plant okay so now we have biology on our
side I'm a biologist so that's why I'm
proposing a solution to the climate
change problem that really involves the
best evolved organism on earth to do it
plants so how are we gonna do it so
biology comes
to the rescue here we go okay so what
you have to remember three simple things
from my talk okay that is we have to get
plants to make more suberin that they
normally make because we need him to be
a little better than what they are we
have to get them to make more roots
because if you make more roots we can
make more suberin so then so now we have
this more of the cells that silver and
likes to accumulate in and then the
third thing is we want the plants to
have deeper roots and what that does is
we're actually the plant actually okay
make stable carbon more than you used to
and then bury it for us on the ground so
they can do that if they make roots that
go deep
rather than meander around on the
surface of the of the soil those are the
three traits we want to change more
super and more roots
and the last one deep roots then we want
to combine all those traits in one plant
and we can do that easily and we will do
it and we are doing it actually in the
model plant in Arabidopsis which allows
us to do these experiments much faster
than we can do in another big plant and
when we find that we have plants that we
the traits all add up and we can get
more of them more suberin in those
plants we're going to move it all we can
and we will beginning to do this move it
to crop plants and I'll tell you why
we're picking crop plants to do this to
do the work for us and and when I get to
that part of my talk okay so I think
this is some science behind the whole
thing
and so I know we can do the science I
feel pretty confident about that and the
reason is because just in the last year
we've been able to find single genes who
that affect each of those three traits
in something in many cases in several of
those cases two out of the three we have
more than one way to get there so that
tells us we might be able to even
combined within a trait get me even more
suberin and so this shows us one result
where we have a plant here on the right
that's making more than double the
amount of root than the plant on the
left and that's just because of the way
we express one gene that's normally in
the plant in
slightly different way than we did then
plant usually does on its own all right
so that's just one example I wanted to
show you and now I want to tell you that
you know we still have a lot of
challenges actually when we get to this
problem because it takes them so we have
to get the farmers to actually buy the
seeds or is it release the seed company
to buy seeds that farmers are gonna want
to have and so we when we do the
experiments we can't actually take a
loss in yield because we really doing
these experiments say to beginning about
ten years from now the Earth's
population will be even more than it is
right now and it's rapidly growing still
so by the end of the century we have 11
billion people we have wasted ecosystems
that aren't really going to be able to
handle all the world that they have to
take from agriculture and then we also
have this competition for land and so we
figured to do this carbon sequestration
experiment actually requires a fair
amount of of land so we can't take it
away from food because we have to feed
the people that are also going to be on
the earth until we get past this big
crisis of in that and the climate change
is actually causing loss of yield all
over the earth so why would farmers
wanna buy seeds that also if it's going
to impact yield so we're not gonna let
it impact yield we're gonna always have
checks and balances that says you go or
no going that experiment and then the
second thing is is when a plant actually
makes more carbon and buries it in the
soil like that almost all the soils on
earth are actually depleted of carbon
because of the load from agriculture
trying to feed 10 billion or 8 billion
people which is what lives on the earth
right now and so that is also a problem
as well and so but so be putting so
plants are making more carbon those
soils become enriched in carbon and
carbon and rich soils actually hold
nitrogen and they hold sulfur and they
hold phosphate oven internals that are
required for plants to grow and have a
good yield and they also retain water in
the soil as well so the super will break
up into little
particles and give the whole soil
another a new texture and as we show
that we can get more carbon in that soil
the soil will get darker and so you'll
be able to measure all that and
hopefully that this is going to help us
solve the problem so okay so we have we
have the challenges that a lot of land
do we need to use we have to get farmers
to buy it and that's going to be the
hard thing for us I think because I mean
we don't we're not really salesmen we're
people who like to Google a person
rather than meet them you know what I
mean so that's what scientists have
mostly like okay and so so but we know
now that you know no one can really deny
think the climate is changing everyone
knows that and is here and it's bad and
it's serious and we need to do something
about it but I feel pretty optimistic
that we can do this so I'm here today as
a character witness for plants and I
want to tell you that plants are going
to do it for is it all we have to do is
give them a little help and they will go
and get a gold medal for Humanity thank
you very much
[Applause]
I'll see I mean Wow
Joanne you're so extraordinary so let me
just to be sure we heard this right you
believe that within the next ten years
you may be able to offer the world seed
variance for the major crops like like
what wheat corn yellow rice that can
offer farmers just as much yield
sequester three times four times more
more carbon than they currently do even
more don't know that number really but
yeah you have to be cheery more they
will do more and at the same time make
the soil that those farmers have more
more fertile yes right so I mean that
that is astonishing of the genius of
doing that and a solution that can scale
where there's already scale yesthank
millions and millions of hectares now
that you said it you said it but is it
almost seems too good to be true
your audacious project is that we scale
up the research in your lab and pave the
way to start some of these pilots and
make this incredible vision process
right yes Joe and Cory thank you so much
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]